yeah our eyes you're the lord of the
white you're the one yeah
that's the best i'm excited about that
but can i i want to say that you're
kind of an anomaly in the sense that um
you're one of those guys that we all
have talked about over the years yeah
like i've had conversations with polish
or
about you i've had talked about talks
with sarah tiana
and it's like you're just a mystery
because
i just think that you you should be
50 times bigger than you are
you know
do you feel that or no yeah i mean i do
but i i'm i'm absolutely horrible at
playing the game
so yeah
yeah i can't have i can't have
you know
hour-long fake conversations with
hollywood types where i have to pretend
like i think
what they're doing is great or
whatever that is you know i'm just
really bad at it there's a
for me i try and keep an element of
being genuine that is uh i feel frowned
upon in hollywood in general
i think that's what it is yeah you just
seem like a normal not a weasel like you
i always say the truth shall set you up
he's not a what he's not a weasel like
you
i am weasley huh
but i can't help it because i was raised
with the weasel that's the paulie effect
that's it thank you yeah there is a
paulie effect is there not yes yeah yeah
that's why i got fired from touring with
paulie i think was my oh my body was
rejecting weaseling
really
did you do anything strange on the road
or no depaulie yeah he was always just
like he would try and just belittle me
it was always like dude come come clean
up my room and pack my bags so that
we're ready
yeah i was like 23 years old i'm like
i'm not doing that yeah yeah they'd
always throw everyone under the bus dude
simone does it bro yeah did he do it no
he tried to do it to me too
and i just wouldn't show up at the table
yeah
because for me it's like i'm not getting
a lot of money
right i'm opening for paul which is
great he's a legend and you know in the
circles that we run in right
so you just go but also when you're
single and back then
you're going
i want to
i think i'm going to get some play here
yeah that is what you think it never
happens never
it never happened any it never i've done
so much play and it never works i mean i
i have zero game in general yeah like he
stacks it up to help like i'm sure you
probably got your own hotel room i had
to share a hotel room with the bodyguard
oh t with terrell yeah oh yeah yeah and
terrell
he used to have this guy yeah t you
don't know tyrell he's like the seven
foot giant dude giant black eye pride of
chicago pride of chicago his name was t
yeah right you don't [ __ ] with t dude
one of the best dudes i've we're the
best known yeah strong
as
[ __ ] yeah also very genuine human being
yeah he like tours now with like
well-known r b hip-hop yeah i saw him yo
so i was in
i was shooting what was i shooting i was
shooting a movie called
keeping up with the joneses atlanta in
atlanta right with zach and those guys i
just coupled out scene but um
i remember being in the hotel
and and um what's the long-haired
magical dj
the magic tv one day you'll get it you
ask it every year i know i text him
every day and i just like pretending i
don't know who he is who are you
of course i know who he is he's one of
the biggest
but i remember he was there
and i was talking to [ __ ] steve aoki
and all of a sudden i was levitating
so i see steve aoki in the [ __ ] lobby
like what's up dude wait i go and i
start levitating
he was there was working for aoki he
picks me up by the neck and he
lifted me off the ground like this and i
talked to steve aoki like this
[ __ ] tea is strong as [ __ ] good man
good man yeah so back then you did it
with tea how about warlock uh no i i
knew warlock from the comedy store from
just smoking cigs and drinking
budweisers on the front patio if you
were described warlock's body who was
warlock warlock
you don't know what warlocks are dude
orlando rick and i come from the
medieval agent warlocks
yeah we had a different time man